Reunited after being separated for over six decades,...
...South Koreans have crossed the border with the North to meet with family members.
The Korean War in the early 1950s divided the country...
...between a communist North and capitalist South.
Many families became permanently separated,...
...unable to contact each other even by phone.
The reunion waiting list has thousands of names.
These are the lucky few, selected through a lottery.
But the reunions are short.
After just a few days, the elderly, sad Koreans say tearful goodbyes.
For many, the long-awaited reunions...
...will be the last time they'll ever see their separated loved ones.